Our portrait forecast view
looks pretty good now.
The next code you're going to grab will
transform the landscape tablet view from
this, into this.
Let's go over how we
accomplish this change.
First of all, you can see that we've
added a linear layout for the app bar,
which has the correct elevation and
blue primary color background.
Next, we see the toolbar,
rendered with the correct themes.
This is a bit interesting.
We want to align the Sunshine
logo with the forecast day.
Rather than hard coding
the calculated value,
we use nested frame
layouts to perform it.
This is a tiny bit expensive but
it makes it easy to create
responsive layouts.
Finally, we look into how we
position the detail view.
This is a nice trick for creating two
even columns in a relative layout.
Create a center strut view that
has no width or height and
ask relative lay out to center the view.
We can then create the forecast fragment
view to the left of this strut view and
a detailed fragment to the right
of the center strut view.
Note that we have to make sure that
the lay out elevation at least
matches the app bar.
Otherwise the detailed fragment
would be included by the at
bar rather then overlapping it and
that's it.
It's actually a relatively
simple relative layout,
given how complex it looks.
Let's take a quick look on where
the portrait tablet layout stands.
Yikes, it's worse than before.
We can fix it.
Here are our red lines for what we
want the portrait layout to look like.
Wow, these overlapping red
lines are a bit confusing.
We can bring the app bar
forward to analyze it.
So, our app bar will be
made in three sections.
The top section is our tool bar
with a height of action bar size.
Image, with a height of
listPreferredItemHeight, and
the bottom section is our spacer view,
with a height of
details_app_bar_overlap, which
we've just added for you.
We use our standard 16 DP padding
around the details fragment, and
for our details fragment, we're
actually going to use wrap_contents.